hey this is presh to Walker you may have
seen this trick which has gone viral and
fascinated millions and millions of
people
you need to calculate the cube root of
the following numbers
the amazing thing is that the cube root
of each of these numbers is exactly
equal to the sum of the digits of each
number
so let's start with the first example
what's the cube root of 512
it's exactly equal to five plus one plus
two which equals eight the sum of the
digits of 512 is exactly equal to its
cube root
the same thing is true of 4913
if we add up the digits 4 9 1 and 3
their sum is 17 and that's exactly the
cube root of 4913.
the same is true for
17576 and nineteen thousand six hundred
and eighty three
there are also trivial cases where the
cube root of one is equal to one and the
cube root of zero is equal to zero
and that's it
if you consider numbers that are greater
than or equal to zero there are only
seven such numbers
these are known as dudany numbers so
this is an amazing result
now as a mathematician the question is
how can we prove these are the only
seven such numbers
it's a little bit of a complicated proof
but I think it's worth going through so
let's get started
the first thing we'll do is we'll
establish an upper bound what is the
largest possible number that could have
this property
once we figure out an upper bound we can
limit our search so that we're not
considering all possible numbers
so in order to do that we'll start off
with some notation let's say N is a
number with K greater than one digits we
don't need to consider K is equal to one
because it's easy enough to evaluate the
single digit numbers and we know that
only 0 and 1 will have this property
every other number the cube will be
larger than its digit
so in this case
n will be greater than or equal to 10 to
the power of K minus 1 and it will be
less than 10 to the power of K
we can write the number as having digits
d k minus 1 d k minus 2 all the way to
d0
and these digits are attached to their
Associated powers of 10.
now from here we know that the cube root
of n is equal to the sum of these digits
so it's equal to d k minus 1 plus d k
minus 2 all the way to d0 we can
equivalently take the cube of both sides
so that we get n is equal to the cube of
the sum of the digits
where do we go from here
we know that each digit has to be
greater than or equal to zero and less
than or equal to 9.
so at most let's suppose that n is just
a number consisting of all nines we know
that's the maximum value we could have
if we have a number with K digits it's
that it has all nines for its digits
so in this case n will be less than or
equal to the cube of the sum
of just nines and we have K of these
nines
so this is equal to 9k and we want the
cube of that
so at most n will be less than or equal
to the cube of 9k
so now we have two different
inequalities and let's put them together
we know that n is greater than or equal
to 10 to the power of K minus 1 but it's
also less than or equal to the cube of
9k
so let's put these inequalities together
and let's start evaluating some values
of K
if K is equal to 1 we have no problem
the same for two for three for four for
five and for six
but now when we try K is equal to 7 we
have a problem
if K were equal to 7
then we would have n less than or equal
to about 250 000 but it has to be
greater than or equal to 1 million and
this is a contradiction because of
course one million is larger than 250
000.
the same thing will happen if we take
any value of K greater than 7 this
inequality will not be true
so from here we can see that we can't
have a seven digit number or an eight
digit number or so on we just won't be
able to get the cube of the sum of the
digits to be large enough
so we know that K has to be less than or
equal to six so we've established one
upper bound but we can narrow this even
further
because we also know that n is less than
or equal to 9k cubed we can substitute
in K is equal to 6.
so then we get n is less than or equal
to the cube of 9 times 6 and that is
equal to the cube of 54.
so this is a good upper Bound for us
n is less than or equal to the cube of
54.
so we need to test the numbers from 0 to
the cube of 54.
and we only need to check the cubes of
these numbers so actually even in the
old days with pencil and paper it would
be possible but in the modern era we
don't need to do such calculations we
can just write computer code
and even if you don't know computer code
you can just ask something like chat GPT
so write code in Python to test if a
number from 0 to the cube of 54 is equal
to the cube of the sum of its digits
chatgpt will say here's code to test
exactly that it'll give you the code and
it'll tell you the code iterates over
the numbers from 0 to 54 cubed
calculates the sum of the digits in each
number checks if each number is equal to
the sum of the cubes of its digits if a
number satisfies this condition the code
prints the number along with the cube of
the sum of its digits
so if we put in this code
we get the following output
we get 0 is equal to the cube of the sum
of the digits 1 5 12
4913 5832
17576 and ninety thousand six hundred
and eighty three we get exactly seven
results
so congratulations you've now proven why
there are exactly seven numbers where
their cube root is exactly equal to the
sum of their digits not only have you
carefully proven it mathematically
you've used python code to figure out
why these are the answers but if you
were to publish this on YouTube or you
were to send it to your boss all you're
going to get is someone who's nitpicking
your results and they're gonna say why
is there a space between this digit sum
and this carrot three you need to fix
this this is ridiculous so if you do a
little bit of research you'll see that
this print statement is formatted in a
way that leads to this space
so you need to find out that you need to
use f strings and in that formatting you
will get this code and this will
eliminate that space between the number
and the carrot three
and you might notice other ways to
refine the code currently we're
iterating from numbers going from 0 to
the cube of 54 but instead we can just
check the perfect cubes within this
range so for that we can change the code
to generate a list of numbers which are
the perfect cubes of the numbers from 0
to 54. we then check the digit sum and
then check if the number is equal to the
cube of the sum of the digits
so we've now figured out once and for
all there are only seven such numbers
with this property it's quite amazing
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time